claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
alors pourquoi cette décision si elle
est avérée intervient tél maintenant
mais je crois que c'est un avertissement
très sérieux envoyé par de la halle
trump à madame merkel est donc à
l'allemagne d'abord parce que comme ça a
été dit dans votre sujet l'allemagne ne
dépense pas assez pour sa défense la
l'économie la plus développée
l'europe est elle est loin d'atteindre
le seuil de 2% qui a été fixée d'un
commun accord au sein de l'otan mais
aussi parce que madame merkel a vexé
monsieur trump sur plusieurs sujets
d'abord elle poursuit son projet de nord
stream 2 le gazoduc entre la russie et
l'allemagne que d'ailleurs la france
soutient aussi et monsieur trump - pour
des raisons stratégiques que pour vendre
du gaz naturel liquéfié américains
s'opposent à cède à cette construction
d'un gazoduc
ensuite madame merkel a probablement
vexé monsieur trump en lui disant il ya
quelques semaines que finalement elle
n'irait pas un g7 s'il se tenait à
cambes évident au mois de juin g7
élargie et puis aussi plus récemment la
semaine dernière elle a parlé d'un
meurtre raciste à propos en effet de la
mort 2
de monsieur lloyd comme vous l'avez
décrit tout à l'heure et puis enfin
peut-être dernière chose monsieur trump
sait pertinemment que l'allemagne va
prendre la présidence de l'union
européenne le 1er juillet prochain et
qu'elle a comme projet pendant ce
dernier semestre de l'année 2020 de
forger une position commune de l'union
européenne vis-à-vis de la chine et d'un
certain nombre d'autres pays qui serait
différente de la position américaine
quelles seraient les conséquences
précisément pour l'allemagne les
conséquences c'est d'abord que les
allemands et bien qu'on les aime donc la
première conséquence c'est que
l'allemagne aurait presque l'impression
d'un désamour de la part des états unis
ce qui est grave probablement pour le
gouvernement allemand
et puis par ailleurs 9500 soldats avec
les familles ça fait à peu près trente
mille personnes ça fait à peu près ça
fait à peu près 3000 personnes et 3000
personnes qui vivent dans les villages
qui sont proches de leurs bases
militaires et qui font des dépenses
naturellement donc ça fera comme à
chaque fois qu une garnison s'en va ça
fera des dégâts dans l'économie locale
et puis je crois aussi que ça provoque
un débat à l'intérieur de la classe
politique allemande est que ce débat
commence à faire des dégâts on a incité
tout à l'heure le ministre des affaires
étrangères mais la mitre la défense
aussi s'est exprimé d'ailleurs dans le
même sens que le secrétaire général de
l'otan monsieur stoltenberg en disant
que la défense de de l'allemagne c'était
aussi la défense des états unis et que
c'était un système global
donc on entre dans un débat que
heureusement nous n'avons pas à avoir en
france puisque depuis 54 ans il n'y a
plus de bases américaines en france
alors blanchemaison quelles pourraient
être les futures relations récisé mans
entre l'allemagne et les états unis
je crois que ça ne changera pas grand
chose parce que ce n'est pas parce qu'on
va retirer 9500 soldats américains que
les choses changent beaucoup d'ailleurs
dans l'article que vous avez cités ont
dit que l'amérique maintiendrait 25000 9
en allemagne 25 mille hommes c'est quand
même un seuil très important qui permet
de faire en sorte que si l'allemagne
était attaquée bien entendu les états
unis seraient nécessairement impliquer
donc je pense que ça tiens ça ne
changera pas grand chose sauf que en
effet les allemands peuvent avoir
l'impression que ceci n'est qu'une
première étape qui sera suivie d'autres
étapes et que progressivement on
arrivera à une situation où la garantie
de l'article 5 de la charte de l'otan ne
sera plus crédible c'est à dire
l'engagement automatique père états unis
si l'allemagne et par conséquent et
l'europe étaient attaqués un projet
militaire européen commun la création
d'une armée européenne comme emmanuel
macron l'atelier de ses voeux en 2017 ce
projet at il une chance d'aboutir à très
long terme mais à court terme de toute
façon l'otan subsiste personne ne
propose le démantèlement de l'otan pas
même monsieur trump et les états unis
ont trop d'intérêt et par conséquent
l'alliance atlantique va demeurer elle
va évoluer mais elle va elle va demeurer
alors par contre la proposition faite
par le président français et je crois
accepté dans son principe par madame
merkel à savoir d'élaborer une stratégie
européenne qui est une certaine
autonomie avec des instruments d'analysé
qui soit proprement européen ceci est en
cours et va se développer
on est encore très loin d'une armée
européenne plus grande coordination
entre les armées nationales en europe
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales de nous avoir
apporté votre analyse